TO THE END OF JUNE TO HELP THOSE
WHO NEED A LITTLE MORE
ASSISTANCE.
>> HAVE MICHAEL OSTERHOLM JOINS
US NOW THE DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH
AND POLICY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
MINNESOTA.
GOOD MORNING, DOCTOR.
WE HEARD THE CDC DIRECTOR SAY
SHE REALLY PLEADED WITH
AMERICANS TO TO DO SOMETHING TO
STEM THESE CASES.
IF WE CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH OF
RELAXING OUR BEHAVIOR, HOW BAD
DO YOU THINK IT COULD GET?
>> WELL, WE HAVE, UNFORTUNATELY,
A ROAD MAP FOR WHAT IT COULD BE
LIKE, IN LOOKING AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN EUROPEAN COUNTRIES
RIGHT NOW.
YOU HAVE MANY OF THE COUNTRIES
THAT ARE IN TOTAL LOCKDOWNS.
AND YET, THEY'RE STILL SEEING
THE CHALLENGES, EVENVY
VACCINATION.
WITH THE NEW VARIANT, B.1.1.7,
THE ONE ORIGINALLY SEEN IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM.
THIS IS A VIRUS 70% TO 100% MORE
INFECTIOUS THAN THE PREVIOUS
COVID-19 VIRUS.
MORE THAN 50% TO 60% LIKELY TO
CAUSE MORE SEVERE DISEASE.
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE STILL OVER
50% OF POPULATION IN THIS
COUNTRY STILL SUSCEPTIBLE TO
THIS VIRUS THIS IS A REAL
CHALLENGE.
>> THE PRESIDENT YESTERDAY SAID
HE EXPECTS 90% OF AMERICANS TO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE VACCINE
WITHIN THREE WEEKS.
OF COURSE, THAT'S GREAT NEWS BUT
PEOPLE ARE STILL HAVING TROUBLE
GETTTING APPOINTMENTS.
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS INCREASE
IN ELIGIBILITY WILL IMPACT THE
TIME LINE ESPECIALLY HOW HARD IT
IS TO GET A SHOT?
>> WELL, I GIVE THE
ADMINISTRATION CREDIT FOR
EVERYTHING THEY'RE DOING AS
GETTING AS MUCH VACCINE OUT OF
THE MANUFACTURING AREA INTO
PEOPLE'S ARMS.
THAT IS VERY GOOD NEWS.
THE PROBLEM IS WE'RE STILL
TALKING ABOUT VACCINATES 2.7 TO
3 MILLION PEOPLE A DAY.
REMEMBER, THAT'S REALLY HALF
THAT NUMBER, BECAUSE THOSE ARE
ALSO PEOPLE COMING BACK TO GET
THEIR SECOND DOSE SO WHEN YOU'RE
ONLY VACCINATING 1.5 MILLION
PEOPLE A DAY IT WILL TAKE A LONG
TIME.
I WORRY OPENING UP VACCINATION
TO EVERYONE, WHICH WE ALL WANT
TO DO, WE WANT TO DO THAT, MEANS
WE'RE STILL NOT GETTING TO
HIGH-RISK PEOPLE THAT NEED
VACCINE THAT ARE NOW BASICALLY
IN THE COMPETITION TO GET IT.
FOR EXAMPLE, THERE ARE STILL 15
MILLION AMERICANS 65 YEAR OF AGE
AND OLDER, THE GROUP THAT'S
HIGHEST RISK FOR SEVERE DISEASE
HAVE NOT BEEN VACCINATED YET.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO BE
CONCENTRATING ON RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT'S A REALLY GOOD POINT TO
FOCUS ON.
NOW FOR VACCINE PASSPORTS WE
JUST HEARD IN ED'S PIECE THAT
THEY'RE CONTROVERSIAL.
WHERE DO YOU STAND ON THIS?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, WE'RE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING.
THE WORLD IS GOING TO DO
SOMETHING.
PEOPLE DO WANT TO KNOW.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO GET ON A
PLANE, IF YOU'RE GOING TO GO
INTO A RESTAURANT, IF YOU'RE
GOING INTO A PUBLIC PLACE, DO I
FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THE PERSON
SITTING NEXT TO ME IS NOT LIKELY
INFECTED WITH THE VIRUS.
WHETHER THE GOVERNMENTS WANT
THEM OR NOT I AM CONVINCED
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THEM
EVENTUALLY BE PART OF OUR
EVERYDAY LIVES.
NOW WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS SORT
OF FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT
SAFELY, FAIRLY AND EFFECTIVELY
AS WE CAN.
SO, I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
IS DOING A GOOD JOB OF AT LEAST
LAYING OUT CRITERIA FOR PRIVATE
SECTOR COMPANIES.
REMEMBER WHEN I GO TO THE
AIRPORT TODAY, TO GET ON A
PLANE, IF I DOO THAT I GET MY
EYEBALL SCREENED BY A PRIVATE
COMPANY THAT DETERMINES THAT I'M
THE ONE THAT IS ACTUALLY THERE
TO GET ON THAT PLANE.
I THINK YOU'LL SEE MORE PRIVATE
COMPANIES GETTING INVOLVED WITH
THE GUIDANCE OF GO